so you think you've got what it takes to
be a hunter equally skilled in long
range in close quarters combat and armed
with the agility to transition between
the two the hunter is an adaptable
roguelike class for those who want to
walk the razor's edge between
survivability and heavy damage dealing
the successful hunter must strike a
delicate balance between the other two
more polarized classes play styles grow
too arrogant during a melee spree and
you'll find yourself devoured by the
fray due to the hunters lighter grade of
armor stay too timid taking pot shots
from a safe vantage point and you'll
soon be flanked and overrun by hordes of
enemies however find that sweet spot
between aggression and reservation
between mobility the ability casting and
the hunter becomes a one-man whirlwind
of death and what better way to
celebrate feeling like a sci-fi Dirty
Harry than with a giant [ __ ] gun well
do your bunk the hunters special ability
sends a golden fire spect hand cannon
for a few rounds of explosively high
damage compare this to the titan and
warlocks of quibbling abilities which
are extremely powerful but only allow
one shot and the advantage becomes
immediately clear well it takes a while
to regenerate this special there are
multiple unlockable skills that shorten
the wait time and for example enable
throwing knife kills to extend its
duration other abilities that help the
hunter to thin the hordes or three
unique styles of grenade each with its
own perks from damage over time to trip
mine sensors these grenades aren't
exactly your ace in the hole but they're
not a bad way to facilitate some alien
murder so don't let them go to waste
climbing the skill tree will also allow
you to spec your character to focus on
toughness speed or recovery in battle
that's directing the play style of your
individual hunter to play the hunter
like a pro stay on the move and keep
your trigger finger itchy but make sure
to try and nail those headshots there
are a variety of class skills that
reward precision kills and every bit of
extra damage buys you a little more
space between the masses and yourself
use your double or triple jump to eject
from any situation that grows too hairy
and try not to get cornered or it's not
going to be pretty the class differences
aren't as pronounced below the beta
level cap of 8 but at higher level play
the hunter has the potential to take on
a heavier stealth and melee focus than
any other guardian the Blade Dancer
subclass becomes available at level 15
and unlocks the cloaking ability
encourages backstabbing and sneaking for
massive damage and charges the hunters
blade with arc light for devastating
melee strikes and special abilities
such as an area of effect blast there's
also a blink that replaces your double
jump allowing blade dancing hunters to
teleport into battle and execute a blink
strike for some bonus damage regardless
of level and subclass the hunter
strategy comes down to mobility and
momentum staying mobile will keep you
alive long enough to gain momentum and
momentum will allow you to do the Lord's
work my son killing aliens skills like
gunslingers trance caused back-to-back
headshots to increase weapons stability
while chain of woe decreases reload
speed in the exact same way other skills
also extend art blade duration during
melee killing sprees and regenerate
health with blink strikes thus while
taking care is essential to the hunter
survival once you get the ball rolling
be sure to keep that murder train on the
tracks play your cards right and the
Fallen won't even see you coming
you